Hey,
what's up everybody?
This is Pat Flynn from smart passive income.com and the smart passive income
podcast.
I wanted to create this video for Tim and for all of you out there who are going
to be starting your podcast very soon specifically to teach you how to record
and edit using garageband.
Now if you aren't going to be using garage band because maybe you're a PC user
or you might prefer something else like audacity or Adobe audition,
that's okay.
Most of those pieces of software all work the same way and this video will still
be extremely helpful for you because I'm going to show you how to be incredibly
efficient when piecing your show together because hopefully you'll just be doing
more than one episode.
Now before we get started,
I got some housekeeping things to take care of that's going to make your life so
much easier down the road.
So let's dive right into my computer and I'll show you what's going on.
All right,
so here you're on the white board,
which is where I'll do.
I'll be doing some instruction here for Ya.
Let me just say what's up to all of Tim's Fam,
what's up Tim's fans.
Now when creating an episode,
there are some people out there who have the ability to complete an entire show
in one full session,
meaning their intro and outro music and even their interviewers sort of recorded
live.
And I'll pleat piece together in one moment and by the end of that their
episodes is ready to ship.
I am not one of those people and most of you probably aren't either.
And I found it very convenient to think of a podcast episode,
sort of like a,
like a movie that's made up of different parts that when put together just
create sort of a seamless show.
And that's how I want you to think about it.
So I'm going to talk about the different kinds of files are the different pieces
of your show,
parts of your show that you can potentially have all recorded separately and
pieced together.
So the first thing you want to think about having is something like a pre roll.
A Pre roll is a unique identifier for each particular episode.
So,
for example,
it might sound like,
Hey,
what's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode 108 of the smart passive income
podcast.
And that is very useful for people because a,
if they've listened to that episode before,
they'd probably know,
you know,
it's good to have order to all of your episodes.
But secondly,
you know,
it gives good identifier for people if they want to share it or reference it
later.
Now that is typically followed by the intro music,
which is always good to have.
Not Everybody has ensured music,
but that's okay.
You could choose and that's [inaudible].
These are really bad notes,
but,
um,
you could choose to have music if you'd like.
That's up to you.
And the music is typically followed by your intro,
your sort of,
uh,
what,
you know,
again,
a unique sort of introduction or welcoming for each particular episode after the
music.
And this is actually really important because this,
this within,
typically the first minute will be the deciding factor,
whether people stick around or not.
And in that intro you want to give all the juicy sort of teasers that you can to
make sure people continue to listen on.
Cause if you don't give them something to look forward to there,
they're just gonna,
they're just going to leave.
Now if you do have interviews,
this is typically were a,
you'd put the interviews and a five,
then you might do sort of a unique,
uh,
post roll,
you know,
something to end the show.
Typically you want to put a call to action in there as well.
And then six,
I didn't give myself enough room,
uh,
the outro music and now each of these different things can be different files
that you could sort of plop together in a timeline.
And Michelle,
you had to do that in the next segment.
But before we do that,
I want to talk about some specific types of files that you should have handy so
that when you do open garageband or whatever editor you use,
it'll just make it incredibly easy for you to find him.
All right.
So right now you're looking at a sample podcast folder and I think it goes
without saying that you should obviously have your own dedicated folder for your
particular show.
But the way you organize those folders within that podcast folder is really
important.
So let me go over how I organize the folders.
And this is again for maximum efficiency in organization.
So first you can see here obviously a folder for all the episodes.
So every time you create a new name,
a new episode,
they get saved in there.
There's one for all of the graphics that you have from your cover art to you
know,
anything that,
anything promotional for your podcast as well that goes in there.
You also want to have a folder for all of your recorded interview.
So whatever recording software you use,
plop them in there.
And then also I like to have a folder for screenshots because you're going to
want to take record of,
of uh,
you know,
the high rankings,
you get an iTunes and elsewhere.
Now let's look at these master files really quick.
This is what's going to save your life.
Having master files incredibly an easily accessible for you each time you create
a new episodes.
So you can see here I have three master audio files here which will be easy to
drag and drop into your timeline.
So I can I,
I have one for your intro.
Uh,
you can have one for your outro as well.
And then if you have any audio transitions in between different segments of your
show,
you can have them in there as well.
And to keep it easy,
I just have them with a little dash in front and all caps so that they're easy
to find.
The dash just puts them at the top when they're putting in alphabetical order.
Now you'll also see a master episode template here.
This is my garage band master episode template.
And this is important because it's a file that you create that you'll open up
each time you record a new episode that will already be set up with all the
proper track names and settings for your show.
This way you don't have to start from scratch with each new episode and mess
with the settings each time.
So let's get into garage band right now and I'll show you how to set up your
master template.
And then after that I'll go over a sample episode with the USO.
You can see just how easy it is to piece your entire show together.
Okay?
So as soon as you open garageband,
you're going to be asked to create a new project.
Now this is the OSTP mavericks version is going to be new versions in the future
and you might be using an older version of garage band.
Either way,
you're going to be creating your master template file the same exact way.
So open up an empty project and hit choose and then you'll be asked sort of what
are you going to do with your particular file.
Now again,
remember garageband was mean for musicians.
So there's a lot of instrumental things going on here.
We don't need that.
You just want to record using a microphone and just make sure the input is on
input one.
Typically,
unless you're doing something different,
uh,
it's going to be on input one.
If you're using the line in on your Imac or your Mac book pro.
So I'm just going to hit create to start our master template file.
Now here's the interface that you're going to be familiar with down the road.
I'm not going to go over every single bit and piece of,
but I am going to give you some specific things to do right and immediately
after you start this file again,
this is to make it podcast friendly because typically a musicians are using this
software.
So the very first thing you want to do is turn off the metronome and that can be
found here on the right hand side.
It looks like a cowbell.
You know we need more cowbell but not when you're recording a podcast episode.
What this is is a,
it keeps time for those musicians that are out there using this software,
but we,
we don't need that.
So we're going to turn that off.
We're going to also turn off this count in which is sort of a pre sort of four
counts before you start recording.
We don't need that.
The last thing you want to do is also change the sort of uh,
led area here from beets to time.
So you want to show the time because you want to know sort of how long your
recording and sort of what time you're at in different parts of the show.
We don't need to know what bar or measure we're in.
So those are the first two things.
If you're not using this version,
you can look around in the settings to change.
Again,
turn off the metronome,
turn off the counting and change from beets to show time.
So those small little setting changes is actually a really helpful for you.
So you could actually save this master template file right now if you'd like.
However,
there's a few more things we're going to do with the tracks to make our life
easier so that we'll know when we drop in or audio files exactly what's going
on.
So let's organize our tracks here.
You'll see one track here called audio one.
We're going to add more tracks,
specify them for different parts of our show,
which will make it easy to drag and drop them in later.
So let's do that right now.
So we're actually going to rename audio one,
two our pre roll.
So if you just double click this,
you can change the name.
So we'll make that pre roll and then we're going to add a new one by clicking
this plus button.
And we're just going to make it the same sort of microphone line input audio
file.
And then I'm gonna rename that one to be intro music.
And uh,
I'll just fast forward through all this so that you'll see them all when they're
done.
All right,
so here you are with our tracks already laid out and I'm going to go down the
list for you really quick.
But before that I want to reiterate why this is important to organize your file
this way.
It's important because you know,
for one it just makes it easy to organize and to know where things go and you're
dragging other files into the,
into its place here.
But it's also important because in the future if you ever want it to change
anything out,
it would be incredibly easy for you.
Or if you go Tim Ferriss style of Va to come in and do it for you.
For example,
if you want to change the intro music or you've changed it later and you want it
to make it cohesive from episode one,
you can come into your older episodes and just interchange the music here or
maybe you're adding or taking out or changing advertisers down the road.
If you had a track for advertisers,
you could do that.
Now we get these lists of tracks here,
this list here,
it's,
it's just a recommendation.
You can add your own tracks if you have other things you could subtract tracks.
It's up to you.
Now,
let me go down the list really quick.
You have your pre roll,
your intro music,
your introduction,
and then you'll see two different interview tracks.
The purpose of that is one track for your voice and one track for the person
you're interviewing.
And the reason you want to separate those tracks,
and I'll show you how to do that in a second,
but the reason you want to have them separated here is because sometimes the
people you interview,
they don't have the best audio quality or their levels might be too high or too
low.
You can adjust them here to match yours so that it's just a seamless sort of
audio experience going through your show.
Then you also have your post role and your outro music as well.
Another thing you could do to make your life easier is if you know that your
intro music is going to be the same in every single episode that you have,
you might as well include it in your master template file to drag and drop any
audio file into your timeline in any track here.
I'm gonna show you how to do that right now,
so open up your find your finding audio file doesn't have to be an MP three you
could be like a wave or an aiff.
You can drag it and drop it right into that particular track.
So this is the intro song.
So I'm gonna put it into this track here and you know for your template file I
wouldn't worry about where it is cause you can move it around later if you'd
like.
But I'm just going to a habit there and you know,
I'll play it for you just really quick so you can hear it.
Welcome to the smart passive income podcast and that's it.
So you could see it going across this timeline.
It's made up of different wave forms and you can even move and shift this into
different tracks if you'd like.
It's really easy and intuitive.
But for now I've done all I can to prepare my master template file.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to click file and save as,
and I'm going to name this,
uh,
the Dash a master episode templates.
So it will always be at the top and hit save.
And congratulations,
you have your master template file,
the file that you're going to open every time you record a new episode.
The most important thing to remember is when you open this file to save as the
new episode that you're recording or else you're going to forget and you're
going to overwrite your master template.
So that's it.
Now let's a reopen this file and do just that and then record our first session
together and actually really quick,
let's fix just a couple more things.
Let's highlight the pre-roll.
Let's move back to zero and a we could turn off the library by clicking on this
button here to give us more room and then let's save it again.
That way when we reopen it,
it'll look just like this.
Okay,
so when you reopen Garageband,
you'll see the same screen as before.
You can actually go to your recent files and open the file from there or you can
just go to your finder window and opening here as well.
All right,
and here we are back at the timeline.
Now what's the first thing we do when we open this template file?
We save as for this particular episode.
So I'm going to go into the episodes folder and create a folder that is named at
zero zero one since this is episode one,
it's good to have a specific folder for each episode as well in case you want it
to record different versions or you wanted to archive versions or whatever other
things to go along with the episode.
It's just nice and clean.
And then I'm going to name this zero zero one.band band is just the garage band,
a file extension.
And here we go.
Now we're all ready to record pre roll.
So I'm going to do that for you right now.
This intro song is here already,
which is good but I'm going to move it out of the way cause we don't need it.
Now you can also mute it if you'd like it by clicking this mute button
underneath,
which uh,
we turned to blue and I'm just going to make sure that the pre roll track is
highlighted.
And then when I press this red button,
it's going to record.
And then I'll,
whatever I say will be recorded into the episodes.
So here we go.
Okay.
Hey everybody,
what's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode one of the sample Tim Ferris podcast.
There we go.
We're done.
Now let's listen to it.
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
What's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode one of the sample Tim Ferris podcast.
Now did you know this,
that click sound for my mouse at the end?
We obviously don't want that in there,
so I'm going to move the sort of timeline cursor here a little before the end
and you'll sort of see where you're speaking based on where these wave forms
are.
And I'm going to hit command t that splits that track at that point in time,
and you'll see it's highlighted and I can just hit delete and it goes away.
So now let's listen to it again.
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
What's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode one of the sample Tim Ferris podcast.
Boom.
I'll get to go now.
Let's unmute the master intro and I'm going to scoot it over back here and you
again,
you'll be able to see where everything lines up.
Again.
Remember that graph I made sort of pretending it's sort of like a movie that,
well,
this is where all the magic happens.
So now we're just going to test it a little bit.
You can just click around and see how it sounds,
and again,
I can make it,
you know,
I can shift it around if it doesn't sound good,
but let's,
let's play it Ferris podcast.
Welcome to the smart.
Sounds good.
Now if I want to get a bigger overview of what the show looks like as far as a
timeline,
I can use the horizontal zoom here,
sort of a zoom out just to get more of an idea of what room I have.
And of course it only goes up to a minute now because we haven't recorded
anything else,
but I'm gonna do more right now and you'll see it just go up over time.
But next I'm going to record the introduction now,
making sure the introduction track is highlighted.
I'm going to your recording,
you'll hear the episodes intro before I record and that's there to help me.
Again,
I don't want to meet that because I want to know exactly when it's time to come
in.
So I'll again,
I'll do a very short truncated intro for you because this is just a tutorial a,
but you're just check it out.
I'm gonna hit record right now.
What's up everybody?
Pat Flynn here.
Thank you for coming on to today's episode.
I appreciate you guys,
Blah Blah Blah.
Today's episode,
so on and so forth.
Don't miss it.
And at the end make sure to catch this,
this and that.
Boom.
Here we go.
Here's the interview with Tim Ferriss.
Okay.
And stopped it.
And uh,
there we go.
So let's hear how all that sounds together.
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
What's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode one of the sample Tim Ferris podcast.
Welcome
to the smart passive income podcast where it's all about working hard now so you
can sit back and reap the benefits later.
Now your host who cannot wait for football season and start again,
Pat Flynn.
What's up everybody.
Pat Flynn here.
Thank you for coming on to today's episode.
I appreciate you guys,
Blah Blah Blah,
and today's episode,
so on and so forth.
Don't miss it.
And at the end make sure to catch this,
this and that.
Boom,
here we go.
Here's the interview with Tim Ferriss.
Okay.
And we're done.
Now I'm going to a zoom in here a little bit so I could see the end and just so
I can make sure to get rid of any clicks that might be there.
So again,
command t delete.
And again,
that's kind of how the show is put together.
Now let me give you some tips as far as the interview is concerned.
I'll drop the interview track.
Uh,
I did an interview with Tim Ferriss a while back.
Um,
and I'll just sort of put that in here.
I'll add the post's role and outre music and then we'll be done.
Uh,
and then I'll show you some tricks for exporting and making sure everything is
leveled off as well.
But let me go into the interview folder really quick just to give you some tips.
As far as the interviews that you're capturing.
If you're using call recorder for Skype,
this is a tool by he cam.
You'll see that the episodes that you recorded,
the interviews that you recorded actually movie files and the reason it's a
movie file is because you know you could record a movie.
You know the,
the the what's on the screen if you're actually seeing video,
but since it's audio it's,
it's a movie file but it's just audio and you could actually change this to an
MP three directly from the tools that he cam and call recorder provides you
right here in your finder by right clicking and go to open width.
Now you could just convert this directly to an MP three it turns it into an MP
three file and then you could drop it in a timeline in one track.
But I like to split movie tracks.
They're split size the conversation or split move we tracks.
I just found that split movie tracks is just a better as far as the Vr is the
quality that comes out.
So I'm just going to click split movie tracks and it'll take a little bit of
time,
but you'll see in just a moment that you'll see track one and track two show up.
Okay.
Now one of these tracks is actually my voice and the other track is Tim's voice.
Now here I'm going to do the same thing except turn it into an MP three.
So now I'm turning each side into its own MP three which I'll then drag and drop
into the timeline.
So I'm going to open with convert to MP three the latest version.
This is track one.
Okay.
Takes a little bit of time,
but you know,
I'll fast forward for the purposes of this tutorial.
All right.
And so now we have the Tim Ferriss interview track one in Tim Ferriss' interview
track too.
And I'm just going to shrink this down so I could show you how to drag and drop
them in here.
And so we have track one.
Ah,
where'd it go?
Okay,
track one.
I'm just going to drag it right here
and it takes a while to convert,
especially cause he's interviews sometimes go for several minutes,
but just be patient.
Now I'm going to do track too.
I'm going to make sure that the beginning is at the same point in time as the
other one that because again,
you want the conversation to be very natural.
I mean if it's off a little bit,
somebody who's going to answer before somebody else finishes a question,
it's going to be weird.
It's happened before.
It's okay.
You can always move these things around.
If you don't get it right now,
just let me zoom in just to make sure.
Yep.
There at the same time.
And now I'm going to play the beginning of this.
Um,
however,
note that typically when I start recording these interviews,
and this might be the case for you,
um,
I'm not recording at the very moment.
We actually start the part that we want in the podcast and just might be small
talk,
but I'm not going to play the whole thing for you.
I'm just going to play the beginning.
So let's hear what it sounds like.
All right,
I'm all yours.
Here we go.
Three,
two,
one.
What's up everybody?
I'm so happy to welcome back Mr Tim Ferriss to the smart passive income podcast.
What's up Tim?
How are you?
I am great.
I'm enjoying wine and weather in San Francisco while it lasts.
All right,
and that's it.
Now I'm just going to cut this short.
So I'm going to highlight both of these click command t just to delete all of
that because I want the tutorial if to be very short for you obviously,
but that's track one and track two.
And as I play these I could notice the different levels here.
You'll notice that as I was speaking,
you've probably seen this already or have noticed it cause it's the only thing
moving on the screen.
Uh,
but these levels sort of go up as the voice becomes louder and if they are in
the red like for a very long time,
that's going to mean that the people listening it's going to crackle in their
earphones or on their computer.
You don't want that to happen.
The,
if the audio is in the yellow or maybe just a tad bit at the bottom part of the
red.
That's good.
And you want both tracks to be there.
Luckily Tim was on some good equipment,
which he's told you in this particular tutorial for the podcast as well.
Um,
so there's no worries there.
But like I said before,
sometimes people aren't on good equipment or their levels come out different.
Um,
but I'm gonna show you a little trick,
even if you can't,
you know,
mess with the levels enough where it does.
Sounds good.
There's a tool out there you can use to make the levels of,
of everything in your episode all the same.
And I'll show you how to do that in just a sec,
but let me just finish up here with the post roll and then I'll draft a drop in
the outro music and then we'll export.
So I'm going to highlight post's role and I'm going to just come back a little
bit so I can prepare myself Francisco while it lasts.
All right.
I hope you enjoyed that interview with Tim Ferriss.
You can find him at,
um,
all the places you all know where to find them.
And you could find me at all the places you all know where to find me.
Thanks.
And I'll see you in the next episode.
That was a terrible out-tro.
Obviously you want to call to action,
you know,
subscribe to my email list,
download my ebook here,
that sort of thing.
But again,
just for this tutorial.
And then the last thing I'm gonna do is plop in the outro music.
Uh,
so let's get the out true music here as well.
And again,
I can move it around and I'm not even going to play it for you,
but you kind of get the idea.
So let me kind of zoom out here so you'll see exactly how this episode's laid
out.
Pre-Roll,
the intro music,
the introduction,
the interview on two different tracks,
the post's role that I just recorded it,
and then the outro music.
And there you go.
So that's the episode.
So now what you want to do is click share an export song to disk.
And this is where you'll get a few different options.
Um,
I like to name this the same exact as it was before.
Zero zero one and I want to do,
do it as an MP three just comes out a lot better as far as file size because
again,
you're going to be doing a lot of these,
but you know,
you know,
let's look at these qualities really quick.
You know,
medium or high is,
is okay.
I mean typically if you're doing music,
highest quality is what you want,
but you know,
you have some music in your show typically.
So I mean,
I usually do it at high quality and click export
and it's not going to take much time because this is a short episode and boom,
we're done.
So we'll see the file here.
Let me go into episodes and then episode one you'll see the MP three file.
And uh,
you know,
if I wanted to,
I could play this and we could hear what it sounds like.
Okay.
Hey everybody.
What's up?
This is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode one of the sample Tim Ferris podcast.
Welcome to the smart passive income podcast where it's all about,
okay.
And I'm not going to play the whole thing for you.
But that's,
that's the idea.
Now the last thing I wanna give you is a tip for leveling.
Leveling out your show,
meaning keeping the volume as loud as it can without crackling for all parts of
your episode.
Whether you don't come in with the best quality or your settings might be off,
or maybe the person you're,
you've interviewed,
their settings are off.
So I'm going to take you to a site called auphonic.
That's Auph oh nic.
And I'll show you how that works.
Okay,
so here we are at a phonic Dotcom,
a cool tool that I use after every episode just to make sure things are good.
You know,
it reduces a lot of noise and hum,
it makes all the loudness all normalized in the same,
you know,
sort of balances the levels for everybody that listens to the show.
So let me show you how to use it really quick.
I'm going to login and I'm use one password here.
Okay.
And you'll see that I've done a number of episodes in the past already for a
number of different shows that I've done.
Now I'm going to click on new production.
Now note that they give you at this point in time,
at least two hours for free to do that.
For some of you might only be two episodes,
but you know,
you could try it out,
see if you like it.
Pricing is based on,
you know,
bulk purchases and you know,
all that stuff.
I won't go over that right now.
But again,
it's a really cool and handy tool that I use.
It comes with a lot of features as well.
You can even export your file after it goes through all that normalization stuff
and,
and balancing with all the basic metadata that you want for your show.
You can use this if you want for,
but I'm sure Tim or somebody else will teach you how to do that.
Um,
you don't need to do that.
I just do it through iTunes specifically so I can drop my artwork in there and
all that stuff.
So I'm just going to use this just to normalize these particular episodes and
I'll show you how to do the one we just did.
Somebody Click on choose file.
I'm going to go into our podcast folder,
click on episodes,
get that MP three file that we just got.
Click open and I'm just going to go down to the bottom and you know the default
settings are already there.
And a hit start production and then hit start production again.
Yeah.
And you'll see it's not going to take that long because the files are really
short,
uh,
but it'll show you sort of a way for him and in,
in a,
in a place to download that particular episode.
And all right,
that episode is done.
Um,
I'm going to click download just to download it to my computer and that's the
main file you want to use as far as putting committed data in your cover art,
upload to your server,
whatever server you end up using.
And then,
uh,
you know,
having your RSS feed from your blog,
um,
and then have it sent out to iTunes and everywhere else you have it.
So before I let you go,
there's one final thing I want to say.
Thank you so much for watching this tutorial.
I really hope it was helpful for you.
Now my final piece of advice for you is this.
Please,
please,
with the information I just served with you,
please create a test episode first.
Don't wait until your first interview.
You don't wait until you record your first episode.
Do it now.
Record a 32nd conversation with a friend.
Put it through this process and see what it sounds like.
Actually listen to that episode on your desktop,
on your laptop,
and especially in your mobile device because most people are listening to
podcast episodes on the go.
Do that and you're gonna know exactly what to fix if it's not right and you're
gonna make your life so much easier.
Thank you.
And I'll see you at the top of iTunes.
Tim,
thanks so much for giving me the opportunity to be here and share with your
audience.
For those of you out there who want more from me,
you can go to smartpassiveincome.com and you can also find me at Pat Flynn on
Twitter.
Thanks,
and I'll see you around.
Thanks for watching this video.
Guys.
If you want more videos,
please let me know what you would like to see,
how to instructionals,
whatever it might be in the comments,
and please be sure to subscribe to this youtube channel so you don't miss any
new videos that I put out.
We'll be doing a lot in video and TV and there's some very cool stuff coming.
Thanks for watching.